well hello congratulations
three seasons yeah are you guys right
yeah are you gonna celebrate are you
gonna pop some champagne are gonna buy a
handbag or bring in the champagne did
you guys bring the champagne we just
found out this is how we celebrate when
you press yeah I feel like we are gonna
celebrate we definitely have to yeah I
we should buy like something nice buy
each other cars with each other new car
no we have to wait till we are with our
cast you know it's just Jenna and I here
unfortunately Ryan right no no I mean I
love being here with Jeff I mean Ryan is
back in New York directing an episode of
the show right now
Jaakko Ana Pomfrey mother all in New
York we got it once we're all together I
think we'll definitely have a giant
jumping group hug and spaz out being
that you guys are such good doctors on
the show I think the people in your
family just think you know everything
like do they come up to you and say like
my ear hurts what do you think this is I
mean I get it
not my family so much I do get people
coming out to me on the street like hey
some my cousin as a kid who's like got
some behavioral issues I'm like can I
ask you a couple things and I have to
tell them like hey you can I don't know
that I can vouch what I'm actually gonna
say to you but I actually ended up
arming myself with a lot of links and
information from websites I can give
people because I can't start buying my
own hype you can't start talking like
you're a psychologist this doesn't does
it won't work out well for anybody
because he got advice from Tyler Labine
I put myself in that position now when
you look at the script is there ever
like medical terms that you're like I
got a Google or how do I pronounce that
like what's the craziest thing you've
said all the time but we're very lucky
that we get we get pronounciation
Dropbox so of how everything's
pronounced and also pronounced in other
words for a real doctor and a real nurse
on set at our disposal and often they
have like what I find really useful
about that rather than just googling it
and seeing what it is they always have a
story about a patient who had this so it
puts in context for me I find that like
invaluable and I couldn't do my job as
well as I do without them we get a ton
of links yeah it's a like actual
cases precedent set and one of our head
writers is a doctor yeah who only
stopped practicing he's amazing David
Foster yeah Icom doc so obviously huge
fans so many of them all over and loving
the show it's been a while since you
guys have been back because of the
holidays the last time we saw you guys
the team was going to Rikers Island
which was so cool
but what can we expect as we've been
waiting so what's this new episode gonna
be take it away
Rikers comes to new stop really pops off
we say goodbye to someone in this
episode that airs on Tuesday don't freak
out don't freak out it's a pretty big
episode and it was directed by Craig
Zisk who perform this is us director so
great big producer to like really really
amazing directory Island well this show
is getting compared to this is quite a
bit even just even on the carpet saying
it's like the new this is I just like to
keep crying they just want to keep
crying and keep crying more tissue it
really it's such a compliment an anomaly
in itself and I think the fact that we
just got picked up for three more
seasons yeah we'll take any of the
comparisons to that show we will we will
ride those coattails as far as possible
yeah where are your characters evolving
to I know you had to have addiction
issues you're from Brampton yeah sorry
we'll get the represents happy town but
bucks blah I know your character has a
tumultuous marriage happening you're
battling addiction issues coming back so
where are we gonna see your characters
because we're all in suspense what can
you tell us I had such a big arc in
season one and I think season 2 is about
like living with addiction and managing
it with her job also there's a new
addition to the cast
and it's a family member of mine which
I'm really excited eyes an incredible
actress so yeah so I think it was gonna
be very excited about that
scoop falling apart yeah it's hit the
skids with Iggy and Martin aghh Marv as
we're calling them probably ill-advised
no the the sort of adoption plans are
moving ahead with Iggy without telling
his partner which was really really
silly are coming to a head and Martin
has obviously found out about it in
episode 10 is really about us
confronting each other about what that
really means on a deeper level like why
I did that
maybe he's struggling in some ways that
he's not being totally forthcoming about
and Janet mentioned that she had a huge
arc with her addiction in season one and
two and Iggy was there for her and sees
one and we just found out that the the
she was gonna be on the other foot for
the second half of season two that bloom
was really gonna be there for eggy and
and some really emotional good actor II
scenes are coming up with me on this one
my favorite right here and of course
lastly you're Canadian
I am I'm very Canadian I'm very I'm a
hyper hyper Canadian very proud yeah
Brampton grew up in Brampton moved from
Brampton to Vancouver in 91 and then and
then I lived in Vancouver and LA for
many many years and I finally just bit
the bullet like five years ago and moved
completely to the States but I've
already got my exit strategy in place
I'm thinking I'm think about coming back
I'll be there